the Texas family was forced to spend
Christmas without their father after you
shot and killed doing his job
Cesar Montelongo was the head of
Maintenance at an apartment complex in
Grand Prairie Texas on Christmas Eve he
was on call and came by the complex to
check on the pipes and several had
bursts because of the freezing
temperatures now he was on an apartment
balcony and the Tenant reportedly
thought that Montelongo was trying to
break in and police say the tenant shot
montalongo through the window he was
rushed to the hospital but eventually
died the tenant stayed at the scene and
cooperated with police but the medical
examiner did rule to death as a homicide
it's now going to be up to a grand jury
to decide if the shooter will face any
charges Montelongo's oldest son Caesar
Jr told a local news station quote we do
forgive the person for what they did and
we pray that the Lord forgives the
person for what they did however Justice
is Justice and fair is fair and whatever
that looks like it's going to be up to
the Lord and the grand jury so Terry
really said case the victim said already
forgiven the shooter but what are your
thoughts on that and by the way could
that impact the grand jury's decision
that statement well I think it's unusual
to do it so soon and yes I do think it
could impact the grand jury and their
ultimate decision look I think that when
families do forgive the shooter or the
alleged shooter or someone who has
killed their family member obviously it
helps them to get over the situation and
it lifts a burden and it does sound like
this family is very religious and that
probably helps them as far as getting
over this real hard tragedy but you know
when you see Victim Impact statements
those two can affect what a jury does at
the end of the day and how the
sentencing goes at the end of the day
and many times we've seen these Victim
Impact statements where they do say they
forgive the individuals so I do think it
has an impact both with the grand jury
at the trial during sentencing and I
think at the end of the day it helps the
individual to get over what's going on
but you have to be careful about that
Jesse and just focusing on the law the
grand jury isn't it all about Brian
whether these Shooter's actions were
reasonable yeah so if the Grandeur is
hearing these charges one of the major
things that any defense attorney is
going to ask has presented the grand
jury is a concept of the castle doctrine
of self-defense this person is
reportedly defending themselves from
what they believe to be a burglar now
the question is what was he wearing at
the time did he have like a uniform
uniform on that would have said that he
was a maintenance worker um was he well
known to the community it seems like
this was an apartment complex but did
this person live in the apartment
complex where they guessed the apartment
complex all of this information and
these facts they say at the balcony
we're talking a first floor balcony we
could just walk up a fifth floor balcony
again all of these facts are going to
add to the cauldron of whether or not
this was reasonable and I think that's
what's going to come down to the
decision as to whether or not it gets
indicted or not yeah very detail
specific in these kinds of questions
these kinds of cases just absolutely
tragic when you see him with his family
yoga students in Mexico reported their
teacher missing last week after he
disappeared on a dog walk only to find
out that he lived a shocking double life
Yogi's knew him as Leon Ferrara but his
real name is Jorge Rueda Landeros he is
a fugitive wanted by the FBI the 52 year
old is the prime suspect in the 2010
murder of Professor suanne Markham this
is a woman that linderos had had a
relationship with Markham was killed at
her home in Maryland and law enforcement
first looked into a man that stole her
vehicle but they eventually cleared him
as a suspect they then turned to
linderos after discovering forensic
evidence tying him to the crime scene
Landeros who has dual citizenship in the
United States and Mexico fled to
Guadalajara and changed his identity but
12 years later he now awaits deportation
to the United States for trial the
question is how exactly do you spot a
fugitive On The Run well we spoke with
former FBI agent Bobby Chacon to find
out what patterns the agency looks for
it's very rare that someone goes to a
place that they have no familiarity with
that they don't speak the language of
course that's probably one of the best
places to go
um but you know because when you're
staying on the Run
um you you're always looking over your
shoulder and so you kind of can stand
out a little bit if you're not from that
area or if you have no connection to it
you've never been there before so you
start looking at places that they've
been or wanted to go to or have some
familiarity on some level with
um and that kind of is the first way you
narrow down geographically where they
might be my assumption is somebody
recognized him from some of the
publicity
um of him being on the top ten I would
imagine that's that's one of the ways
and you know it's it's interesting
because we had a recent case with a
fugitive that was posing as a yoga
instructor down in Costa Rica
um if you remember the case where one
woman killed another woman who you know
supposedly love triangle with a
professional cyclist I think they were
um and then she ran down and became a
instructed in Costa Rica she wasn't from
Costa Rica of course but they got on her
so this is like the second fugitive in
the last couple of months that I recall
that was acting as a yoga instructor
now Brian we have to be clear here that
Landeros is innocent until proven guilty
but when you and I spoke you said there
were two facts that you thought sounded
pretty bad for his case right yeah I'm
looking at this case and I'm and I'm
seeing two things one the DNA under
their fingernails there are reports that
his DNA is under the victim's
fingernails and she was found at the
bottom of the stairs that looks like a
struggle that looks like a fight to the
end well it seems unclear what the
relationship was one thing does stick
out that being the second point is a 500
000 life insurance policy where he was
the beneficiary in the name oftentimes
it's either Love or Money that is a that
is the motivation to murder but if he
left and didn't collect that kind of
raises some eyebrows but like you said
it's innocent I like to say unless
proven guilty but that's just a defense
attorney in me yeah well you I could
kind of see you were actually talking
more like a prosecutor there you're
building the case against them in an
upcoming trial now Terry talking about
the FBI's uh 10 most wanted fugitives I
understand there's only one woman on the
list right what can you tell us about
her you know it's very unusual that a
woman would be put onto the list but
there is one and guess what it's not for
murder her name is ruja ignatova she's
from Bulgaria she's 42 years old quite
attractive woman actually and she was
put on that list in June of 2022 so
quite recently you will never guess why
she's on the list it's for a fraud wire
fraud Securities fraud money laundering
for cryptocurrency so she's in the same
boat as we've seen for um you know Sam
bankman freed but she actually tried to
escape the authority so that's why she's
on that list and she actually had four
billion dollars worth of money that she
took from millions of these people who
invested and actually you know she is
very similar to bankman Freed and they
don't have their hands on her just yet
yeah she didn't have a 250 million
dollar ball is out of going Terry Brian
thanks so much everyone thanks for
joining us here on the daily we're going
to see you next time as we discuss
Justice in America
[Music]